i'm andreas
and i'm here to show you the meta
programming capabilities
of the programming language nimrod which
i designed in my spare time
because i could so
how is this talk structured first i will
explain nimrod in a single sentence
then i'll talk about some of its notable
features and its implementation aspects
then we'll see nothing but code the
famous hello world example with some
twists of course
then i'll show nimrod's macros features
then we'll optimize hello world with
nimrod's germany writing macros
so we're going to optimize the the heck
out of hello world
and then i've another example for term
rewriting macros called hosting
and then i'll give a summary about
what you've seen in this talk and about
what i had to leave out
okay so what is nimrod
nimrod is a statically typed systems
programming language
with a clean syntax and strong meta
programming capabilities
and and the snippets here you can see
that we
have attained mode um that we
support systems programming with a
bitcast feature
you can easily define your own iterators
thanks to
the yield statement that uh looks
comparable to c sharp solution but in
fact works quite differently
differently and
in the last line you can see the actual
definition of the unequals operator in
nimrod
so the unequals operator simply
delegates its work to the
equals operator and calls not on it
and this works on a very general type
here called expression
so um you never have to implement your
own unequals operator
you simply have to implement your own
equals operator and then the unequals
is available thanks to this macro
the template is a declarative macro and
we also have imperative macros
i'll come to that later
okay some of its features we compile to
c
and the large subset of the language to
javascript
we also support c plus plus and
objective c code generation for easier
interfacing with these languages
we have a real-time gc with maximum
pause times of about one to
two milliseconds in the test that i did
it did with it
and i think it's ready for commercial
game engines but we'll see
the compiler itself and all of the
standard library and that includes the
gc
are written in nimrod and the compiler
also performs
whole program dead code elimination for
us so
everything that you don't use is not
included in the final executable and
our standard library is written with
this in mind
for instance the parsers that we provide
don't use regular expressions so if you
use our parsers
your code does not become dependent on a
regular expression engine
and by the way using regular expressions
for parsing is
misguided anyway
[Applause]
yeah the gc is also optimized the way if
you do not use it
but you can also say explicitly that you
don't want to
use it um
yeah it's a bit off the screenshot i'm
sorry um the
our whole infrastructure is also written
in nimrod we have an ide
called aporia we have a build farm we
have build tools package manager
and forum software and the compiler
supports an ide mode so
your favorite text editor can query our
compiler for code suggestions
as you can see on the screenshot here
and it works
um okay now
finally some code this is the famous
hello world
um i added the 99 here to to
have it a bit easier to explain what
happens
now obviously that produces hello world
99
but how does it work actually the
the echo is declared as a procedure
which is
nimrod's word for function
and it takes a valuable number of
arguments
and applies this the dollar operator on
every argument yielding a string
so the dollar is nimrod to string
operator
and there are arguments
mean that the arguments are gathered
into an array
and the the square records denote an
array
this is a local type converter so only
in this echo context everything is
converted to a string for you
and in contrast to c sharps or java
solution that does not require
any dynamic binding whatsoever and also
it doesn't imply
downcasting to object or something like
that
and yet it's still extensible here we
have
a custom type my object and declare that
the dollar for
it just delegated to to the field s
of x then we declare an
object with the value
xyz and echo it and it works
so the the um the dollar in the va
arcs declaration actually refers to an
open set of overloaded symbols here
and that's quite an important feature of
the language
[Music]
okay nimrod's focus is on meta
programming
we use macros to avoid code application
boilerplate
here in this example i declare a macro
in line 1
called html tag that text
takes a tag name and produces a function
of that name and the function
simply returns its name as a string and
angle brackets
so here the ampersand is nimrod's
concatenation operator and ast to string
is a built in that transforms
the the ast to a string and in this case
it transforms the
procedure name into a string literal um
now then we declare two procedures br
and html in line four and five and
finally we
use that br procedure in line seven so
it produces the br and angle brackets
and now the ordinary macros and
templates participate in overloading
resolution in nimrod
but immediate macros do not and so here
we use the immediate because the br and
html identifiers are undeclared
at the point of the invocation of this
macro
and so the compiler doesn't try to infer
a type
for br or html which can only fail
because
these are undeclared identifiers okay
we use macros for control flow
abstraction
here i declare a macro once that takes a
body of code so the body of code is
passed
via the colon indentation in line 8 9
and line 1314 to it
and it ensures that this piece of code
is run
exactly once so
this produces the
first call of p some call of p the new
instantiation and then some call of p
so the once template performs its magic
with a global valuable x
that is a guard and
the global here refers to the lifetime
of the variable and not to its scope
that's pretty important and
the the the axe is uh this
it is a hygienic macro so the x cannot
be used outside
outside the once macro and also cannot
be used in the body that is passed to it
and now if we would
have instead a top level variable x
that would be an ordinary global
variable and
it would have a global scope
in addition to the global lifetime so
this example here shows that
the x is there's a new fresh x produced
for every instantiation
so if as you can see um p
only executes once the first call of p
but if we do pass another thing in line
14
new instantiation then it still produces
this
code because the the variable x is
duplicated
okay we use macros for lazy evaluation
purposes
this is the famous logging example in
nimrod
here the message parameter is evaluated
in a lazy fashion
and so if debug is set to false someday
the
expansion expensive string
concatenations or to string operations
in line 5
won't be performed so ordinary
function evaluation i mean the the
argument passing is
eager but for templates it's lazy
okay we use macros to implement dsls
domain specific languages here we
declare an html generator
of the name main page and then
has a head and a title and body
uli tags and
then we execute this main page generator
and this produces the the html code that
you can see here
and now i'm
going to show how this is implemented
again we have a couple of templates
in line one the the html template
declares our
generating proc so it takes the name
of the procedure and the the statement a
list of statements that's inserted
into the body in line four and we start
with
setting the result variable to the open
html tag
then we perform the the steps that are
passed to it and then we append
the closing html tag and the result is a
special variable in nimrod that
represents the return value so there is
no need
to to have a return result
as a final statement here now the
the nested tag template is a template
that produces a template of name tag
and again we simply append to result
the tag name then we insert the
statements
and then we append the the closing tag
and simple tag 9 13 is quite the same
except that it doesn't take a statement
list but a single expression instead
and with the help of nimrod's
percent operator we produce a
soup of tags and angle brackets
so the the substring dollar one and
dollar two in line 15
are replaced with their corresponding
arguments here
and then these these meta templates are
used to
to declare the the final templates which
are body head
ul title and ally so after
the first round of macro expansion
this code is produced here and
i think it should be pretty obvious by
now
how this works so this dsl
is actually translated into a single
procedure main page
that does some pretty boring stuff in
fact
it's just a couple of string
concatenations
and string formatting operations and
now if we invoke this procedure main
page the compiler
recognizes that this is side effect free
and evaluates it at compile time
so this is all optimized into this long
string literal here
yeah we use meta programming
to provide user defined optimizations
via nimrod's term rewriting
macro feature now we've seen that
compile time function evaluation already
helps quite a lot
but sometimes it can fail
and i'll show how so back to the
hello world example here we declare a
type my object
with two integer fields a and b and the
string field s
then we produce a value of it
with the values 3 4 and abc respectively
and then we again simply echo it
and again now this time it uses nimrod's
built-in string a built-in dollar
operator for object
which is declared in nimrod system
module
which is quite like haskell's prelude um
yeah so this time there is no
overwritten dollar that could
be invoked instead
okay the implementation of the dollar
operator for
ordinary objects looks like this so we
have a generic here
in line two a generic type t
and the the colon object is a generic
type constraint
so this is the dollar for every type t
that happens to be an object and
again it's pretty much straightforward
code except that
we rely on a built in field pairs
iterator for this to work
so the fieldpass iterator takes an
object and yields the the
the field name and its corresponding
value
what oh no
um okay
um the the built-in fields iterator
transforms the for loop
into the following and
so it unrolls the loop at compile time
and now the the task is to optimize that
code as far as possible
and the desired result here is um
this thing so it's a it's a single
concatenation
where everything has been evaluated as
far as possible and note that the object
a object.b stuff is not known at compile
time
so we need to we can't do anything
further with that
okay to to eliminate the the percent
operator
we want to evaluate it partially
and so the let's have a look at the
implementation of the percent operator
um again this this passes the format
string f
with the help of a local variable i in
line three
and then it appends either f at position
i
in line 16 or it depends the the past
argument in line 12 a at position j
minus 1
okay so and now we transform that
into a term rewriting macro
[Music]
here the we can't use a declarative
approach
but instead use an imperative approach
so it's a macro and not a template
and here we
uh the we match against the pattern and
the pattern is given the curlies in line
one
and so the pattern reads it's an
invocation of the percent
for of f and a where f is a string
literal
and a is the the array of strings now
here the important thing is that f
is a string literal so it's known at
compile time
and so we can perform the
partial evaluation so the macro here
transforms the the matched pattern into
an ast
and the ast is a single call expression
of the ampersand in line two and here we
either append
um the the character literal f at
position i in line 16
or we append the a at position j minus
one and line
and again here we operate not on strings
but on
ast nodes okay so this implements the
the
optimization and this produces the the
following result
and now thankfully the compiler performs
a variant of constant folding for us
producing um this instead so some
concatenations have been eliminated
and now all that's left to do for us is
to eliminate the the add operations
and again we do this with nimrod's term
rewriting
here the the optimization rules are
simple enough that we can use a
declarative approach
so we have two rules opt at one and
update two
and the the rule object one reads x
is assigned y and then set is a pendant
where we can transform that into
x becomes y concatenated with set
the second rule is similar but i'll skip
it now
and the by the way the names for the
term rewriting
macros are only here so that we can
disable it easily because these
optimizations turn out to be tricky and
buggy
okay so how does it work
the the orange line is matched against
the orange
part of the pattern the yellow line
against the yellow part
and this is then transformed into a
single assignment
the blue stuff and then the rule applies
again
and produces an even longer assignment
and it goes on and on until every single
ad
expression has been eliminated now we
still have some nested
concatenations here but thankfully the
compiler performs constant folding again
and it produces the the final result
that we wanted
so everything has been eliminated as far
as possible
now the implementation of the percent on
the
opt format optimizer looks suspiciously
alike
can we perhaps avoid the code
application yes of course
it looks like this and here the
common implementation has been extracted
into a format implement template
which has been parametrized because we
either need to do nothing with the
character or we need to transform it
into a
character literal so it's i either it
operates again on
strings or on ast nodes
and to do nothing we pass the identity
template in line 19 to it
so identity is simply another template
that
doesn't do anything with its x
and yeah as you can see in the other
case in line 22 the new
new literal function is passed to it
okay so i've now uh
yet another example for nimrod's german
writing macros
um here in line 30 until 5 15
we iterate over every
line in the file input txt and if the
line matches some regular expression
that looks like a key value pair we
output the key value pair
and now normally the the re constructor
that is defined in line one would be
invoked for every single iteration but
thanks to term rewriting macros we can
optimize that so in line
four we say if it's again a string
literal
we can reduce the parsing of the string
into a regular expression just once
and store it in a global variable g and
use that valuable g
instead in line 6. so this implements a
form of
invariant code hosting
okay there's another thing that oh yeah
and um
by the way pearls performs the same
optimization but in perl regular
expressions are built in
in nimrod there's no need to that
there's no need for that we can
optimize them in the same way anyway
okay some another detail is the the
equals tilde matching operator that
delegates its work to a
match function in line 11 so that's not
the interesting part
the interesting part here is that in
line 9 and 10
we inject into the invocation scope
of variable matches which is an array of
strings
if the scope has no matches
symbol already so the the marches array
is injected and used then in line 15
implicitly now this is a highly
controversial language feature but
it's quite useful and perhaps not in
this case but in other cases
okay now the summary we have seen how
compile time function evaluation helps
to optimize the code
what we didn't see is that nimrod also
has that agreed and static exact
functions so static read
reads in a file at compile time and
transforms a string literal out of it
static exec executes some external
process
captures all its output and transforms
it into a string
we have seen nimrod's declarative and
imperative asd-based macros
we've seen they are both hygienic and
dirty
we have seen germany rewriting macros
what we didn't see
is that the sub language that defines
patterns is actually quite sophisticated
so you can request that the pattern has
no side effect or that
some expression does not alias with some
other expression
and that's pretty important to get these
optimization rods right
we also didn't see source code filters
which is yet another way to produce html
code
and we have a programmable annotation
system
so the curlys and the dots that you saw
are called pragmas in nimrod
and you can define your own and
transform them via macros
okay what we also didn't see is quasi
quoting
here the inline four the we have the so
the built-in quote that produces an ast
for us in a easier way than dealing with
the asd
api
yeah it's pretty much obvious what it
does it produces an
if not expression then say look in this
line
the expression failed
yeah okay
thank you for listening um we're always
looking for contributions so please
check out the github repository and
see what's left to do for you and if you
need some nice
ideas about cool projects involving
nimrod join our
ioc channel and i can give you
quite some interesting projects
to to do
um yeah thanks